[Music]
it's storytelling it's creativity it's
marketing
marketing dynamics it's reselling it's
collectibility
i mean it's like creating my own pokemon
or star wars or
smurfs are you kidding me
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for tuning in to what is
it's a special episode of the scoop
because i'm kind of getting a little bit
outside of my scope
we've we've been getting tons of
inbounds from
people who listen to the show and then
of course some of my more
um annoying's a little mean but but
some of my persistent colleagues who
have been asking me to get
someone on the show to talk about the
momentum
maybe even the mania we're seeing across
the
nft market and we've got quite the guest
for you ladies and gentlemen we have
gary vaynerchuk
he is the ceo founder of vaynermedia
early social media adopter an investor
in
the likes of facebook uber founder of
rezzy co-founder
of resi and is a huge name in
collectible trading cards and
has really staked a flag for himself
in the nft market so gary we were
talking a little bit
before we turn on the mics people people
have
uh and i you know an idea of your
background but where exactly do
nfts fit into your story and and walk us
through how you kind of
got introduced to uh this
burgeoning corner of the crypto market
men thank you so much for having me
first and foremost
um it's really goddamn idle this is
let me start with this i literally out
loud
said the following dear god
are you [ __ ] kidding me how did you
possibly
give me this gift of taking every
ingredient
of the last 40 [ __ ] five years of my
life
i'm using all the curses because i want
to be authentic exactly what i said i
curse with god
um which is why i know it's okay by the
way um
and and create this thing called nfts
that's literally everything for me like
supply and demand creativity like i've
had people from sixth grade reach out to
me and say
gary this is crazy i used to think like
you move i moved in seventh grade
like you moved in seventh grade but when
i would think of you or when you popped
on the internet and i was like wait a
minute i know that person i was like oh
a businessman i thought he was going to
be an artist
because i doodled so much in grammar
school because i was such a bad
student so the whole time i would just
draw on my notebook
and like give out like draw on the
chalkboard so not only
is this ip i've always been obsessed
with wwf
disney ip i would always
um like i loved star wars i would always
go to garage sales and buy happy days
and
alf and robocop and get along gang and
sesame street like i've always had this
infatuation with pop culture art
right um i've also i'm very pro
artist in general i've always been like
man i don't understand the economic
chain
of these secondary markets like look at
these collect and i'm a collector
and a seller but like damn i feel like
the person that made it so like this
whole royalties aspect of nft
uh building communities understand i
think this is i think the biggest thing
that people don't understand about nfts
is the artists and projects that are
going to win
are not going to be just on the
subjective nature of humans belief that
this is pretty cool rad
interesting i think it's going to be
based on who knows how to build
community and these artists
are going to love the fact that they get
more of the royalties but what they're
not going to love
for some of them is that galleries and
other people managers were the ones that
cultivated the stories and the
communities
not the artists themselves these artists
that can do both
are going to be incredibly fortunate i
think nfts right now are talking about
art
and and collectibles but i think the
whole space
for my startup technology dna
speaks to me because i think this is
about transactions on ledgers
in a transparent decentralized way
you're talking about selling homes
mortgages insurance i think this is
going to impact the music and
publishing industries in a way that i
don't think people understand
this is a big big deal and
it's happening at a time of my career
where
i have audience which will be helpful
i'm also coming on the back of a four
year run in sports cards when i first
started talking about it
in 2018 everybody laughed at me there
wasn't a single smart person on board
with me that sports cards were going to
happen
none of them and i have a lot of them
around me so now i have the affirmation
of calling something that a lot of
people in my circles clearly did not see
alternative investing
we have the momentum of the bitcoin and
the ico collapse and i'll get into that
in a minute
behind us recently not 2000 which is my
comp
for what i'm about to say about nfts
it's storytelling it's creativity it's
marketing
marketing dynamics it's reselling it's
collectibility
i mean it's like creating my own pokemon
or star wars or
smurfs are you kidding me all investing
in those things it's personalities like
logan paul and charlie demilio and the
baby and ghana these are all humans
that i was on super early because i
understood what they were up to
all those dynamics will play out so i
was thanking god for creating something
that
i will be in the nft space for the rest
of my life
and it's certainly creating something
that is allowing when we think about the
value proposition
or at least how i've come to understand
it
allowing artists musicians to have more
ownership
over the things they create and in terms
of brands if we think about
what it means for brands we saw this
morning
taco bell went live with their nft taco
art
on wearable another way for brands to
engage with
their users how do you see some of the
firms you're working with i think your
clients are
are including um includes tick tock
pepsi some others how do you see big
corporations
um maybe leveraging nfts my
intuition is poorly that's my intuition
and i'll tell you why what do you think
of the taco bell thing is this you know
what i saw the head
yeah i need to see the metadata
right so like these projects are going
to rely on the metadata more than
on the front-facing creative there's
going to be too much supply
for nft projects to be successful
at scale just on the merit of the
creative
i think what people don't understand is
the contracts behind
the art that enable a lot of things so
what i don't know is
is there a golden taco that if you own
it you have free taco bell
every every time you go to one like the
metadata
is what i think these things are going
to really rely on so
my intuition with just a headline
reading and so i hate
doing this my gut is that taco bell once
again
because it's been good at this
understands there's a trend and got
itself into the news cycle
of using it the merit of the program my
concern is
somebody's gonna buy it for 20 bucks or
nine bucks or four bucks
somebody's gonna rebuy it for a hundred
bucks somebody's gonna own it
for five hundred dollars and then is
going to be holding the bag
when it's not worth 500 and i think
that's gonna happen 97
of the time over these next two years my
prediction
which whether right or wrong is
irrelevant but my intuition
is you're gonna see an ico and a
internet 2000 stocks
dynamic here which is the macro is right
cryptocurrency is right which is why
there was even that ico movement
nfps are right the digitalization the
provenance
the ecosystem is gonna happen right
what's what happens in the early days
where there's no restriction
to be in the game it is very easy for
even a person that knows nothing about
nfts right this minute to google and
youtube for four hours
and have their first nft on openc
tonight
that's a very in please no i was gonna
say i'd uh
i'll take you up on that and see if i
can yeah you should do that
and i'll tell you why you should do that
and everybody listening should do it
it's the
greatest way to learn is doing it you
can read about push-ups
it's a lot better to do them and so so
but what i think is going to end up
happening is from taco bell to
mcdonald's
from pokemon to star wars from every 16
year old digital artist
on earth to everybody like me who's had
this hidden little art talent that
they've never shared
everybody is going to be an artist just
like everybody
became an influencer at some degree
everybody became a personal brand
whether they like it or not everybody
has a social
media footprint and when i say everybody
of course not everybody but like
[ __ ] a lot hundreds of millions of
people billions of people
i think you're gonna see the same thing
now imagine what that means
it means that the early stuff right now
on the hype are getting a lot of the
economics
but there's gonna be too much supply and
only the one percent
are going to be these incredible
economies and oh by the way
no different than when star trek came
out just to remind all the nerds
because i'm one there was a million
space movies in between star trek
and star wars and you know black hole
is good ip but it's not worth what
[ __ ] star wars is worth
right you know planet of the apes is
pretty cool
but it's not worth what star wars is
worth and i think that's what you're
going to see but i do
think that there's going to be a
collapse on a lot of projects and i
think people have to be
very thoughtful about the macro of nft
and
separating that movement from the nft
projects
no different than separating the
internet
from internet stock companies and
companies like pets.com and etoys
they failed but to remind everybody
amazon was
part of that group too and that was a
very good investment
in the year 2000 when all the markets
died and that's how i plan on playing it
so we've kind of looked at the macro
backdrop of what you see happening
um i want to zoom in for folks who are
maybe listening and
still don't necessarily get the value
right
if we wind back the clock to
when we have the cambrian explosion of
social media
you can sort of look back and say
brought us closer together
um allowed us to communicate in ways
we've never been able to communicate
before on an individual level
i can add my cousin that i haven't seen
in five years and we can catch up about
his dogs or whatever have you
what is the parallel for nfts how do we
communicate
that same type of value that seems so
easy to do in hindsight
if you if you if people collect anything
seeing the ledgered provenance of that
matters
so let's play it out just i'm going to
ask both of you just for fun
yes and andreas is here as well andres
is here for everybody who's listening
up from the underbelly of the scoop yeah
he's the man behind the curtain
yeah and i wanted to bring you both in
this because it's a fun question
um what's your favorite movie of all
time
i think i'm gonna have to go with
godfather one great
is there any level of curiosity for you
to figure out who the first person to
buy the first
ticket to the first showing of godfather
one
was yeah that would be that's that's all
you need to know
and it's very important because i'm
using a very narrow example that
everybody can understand
i believe that people do not realize
that we are social creatures
for example i think frank that you are
you have a mustache right now because
you want to communicate to the world
something about yourself with it i'm
being dead serious with you
and i think andres has long hair and i
think people wear gucci belts
and buy nike air force ones and drive
mercedes
and care about having a blue check mark
on instagram and buy fortnite skins
and madden tokens and i can give you 47
other
trillion examples to why this is gonna
work out which is the following
humans want to communicate with humans
so
for example everybody listening right
now they meet someone new whether they
think they're cute
and they want to date them or they want
to do business with them and they
thought it was something important
they will go to either commonly in
today's world
google to google them or
instagram to see what they're about
those are two things that i think the
three of us
are if i'm not supposed to keep bringing
andres in frank you can agree with me
that is here what what people do right i
think we can all agree
i believe that when i meet you in 12
years
and i'm already enjoying this convo i'm
going to go to your public ledger
and i'm going to search and i'm going to
see that you also
are into snorks the rare
underwater smurfs from the 80s or you're
into voltron
or this and that because i'm gonna see
it and i'm gonna
and that i'll give you another example
i'll be able to see that you were one of
the first 500 fans
of nirvana because nirvana in 2027
put out their first demo and sold nfts
against it
and it will document who knew who
nirvana was
and that would have happened in 1991 if
nft was around
i can give you another point of view
nirvana may sell 10
of its first songs master it's demo tape
master
and you might be able to get one percent
commissions because you bought it
like there's a lot here and i'm going
fast and giving some random examples
but social currency is the word that
people have to wrap their head around
with nfts
and i believe the ledger like i'll give
you another example if nfts have been
around forever i'd
i'd probably be looking right now on the
blockchain to our
on the ledgers to find things that randy
the macho man savage once
owned because i want to own them in my
wallet
because i care about providence and
that's going to become
the biggest option aha to everybody when
i said everybody would online date
in 1999 my buddies made fun of me so
heavy
because in 2001 if you were online
dating you were quote unquote
that weird guy in your mom's basement
tinder in 20 i think that might be the
prototype of
nf tiers today so we'll see if
so i think i think today when people
like why do i care about a jpeg i can
just take a screenshot
are going to be the same people that are
going to be in 21 years being like
oh it's interesting because
this is basically one of the biggest
arguments against uh the value of nfts
is that the ownership is really only in
the certificate of authenticity
and because people are the biggest
people because andres i'm starting to
interrupt
because i'm so excited it's because
people haven't taken
the chess move of everybody knowing
and seeing the certificates so you're
saying everyone's wrong this is a
feature
it's not a bug and that is the true
value who cares if it can be duplicated
it's that you have that certificate of
authenticity down the line and it might
change hands but
everyone can see that gary was the first
owner of a particular
top shop moment or something that's
exactly what i'm saying and i would
tweak it in 89 percent of people are
horribly wrong about screenshot it
doesn't mean anything
and 11 currently really really
understand and will reap the fruits of
the benefit
comma i think top shot's one of the most
interesting
projects because it established flow
roham's a beast
it's basketball it's made it pop culture
on the flip side
i think that 98 of the top shot values
will collapse and i'll tell you why not
because tom shot's bad
or roham's bad or or dapper is bad
they're actually incredible
it's because it's like sports cards
there's too many different players like
nobody's gonna care in 21 years
about a terry rozier dunk even though
he's a great player
it's just not going to happen like and i
know that because kevin garnett rookie
cards are too underpriced given his
top 100 basketball player of all time
status
it's not how collecting those kind of
things works
not every pokemon is worth a lot
charizard
is worth a lot and so where people
getting caught is
they're looking at the whole project and
i think they're going to get caught
because there's no demand issues right
now
excuse me no supply issues we don't have
the nfl
nft we don't have mlb nft we don't have
ufc nft we don't have pokemon star wars
wwf but we're going to muhammad ali pele
like harry potter like
it's all coming and that's the increase
is going to have an impact
a huge impact so i think i think
lebron's nft on top shot as a first
project
and lebron is really potentially quote
unquote
underpriced long term but i think you're
going to see the floor
collapse out of it on the individual
stuff
because i don't think the demand will be
able to sustain
because that demand for that guy and
that girl
is about to amortize out to 45 other ips
that haven't hit the market yet
yeah and across an array of different
categories and
and there's a lot of supply of those
things like they're like top shots doing
a great business model for themselves i
think kudo like i love what they're
doing
i do think though that top shot is gonna
have a beanie babies like
moment i really do and i don't see that
happily
i actually think overall that company is
a monster and even the nba top shop
program i think is a monster
i'm talking about the individuality in
it that's like saying
like i don't like in sports cards i've
been saying i don't like these young
rookies i think they're overpriced
but i love sports cards i love
top shot i don't like 98 of the
inventory and they're very expensive
right now
comma at the macro i'm obsessed
with nfts but i think there's all the
dynamics in place
for a lot of the nft projects of today
to be worth a lot less money
in 24 months because there's an
inevitable correction
and then there'll be the birth and i
keep using amazon and ebay
as two stocks that everybody should have
bought
in eight you know in may of 2020
excuse me 2 000 even though the internet
bubble was a monstrous one and everybody
started writing articles
the internet's a fad that's what's gonna
happen with nfts in two years everyone's
gonna be like see
nfts were [ __ ] that's not true
that's
what's gonna happen is a lot of those
projects were mispriced
but the overall macro thesis of nfts
is similar to the overall thesis of the
internet in 2000. and there's definitely
a number of investors who are of that
same opinion as we reported
back in mid-february dapper labs is in
the process of wrapping up a 250 million
dollar round um at a valuation of
somewhere around two billion dollars so
there's definitely people who see
value in this that's a lot that's a
monster
but guess what i don't know the details
but the economics around their top shot
deal
has to be enormous and and
the other thing is let's not forget who
roham and the team are
they did crypto kitties in 2017 i think
is the year 18. these are this is a team
that
really [ __ ] understands this space
and
and a two billion dollar company as a
winning company
in you know 2031 is gonna seem like
peanuts
so it's as crazy as it sounds it's not
far-fetched
now that team flow is a platform all of
that has to work out
but they yeah no i get it i want to
double-click
um really quickly on on maybe some of
the impediments they might face
something that i've thought about and
the team has thought about
is whether or not
um certain licensing agreements might
make things difficult like they're
obviously have have made arrangements
with
with the nba but if they were to move on
to
you know other leagues if they can't
secure the proper
type of licensing or their current
licensing arraignments
arrangements fall through then what my
counterpoint to that
is that's exactly right brilliant i
agree
comma they created crypto kitties
and so like to me if i would bet on
a crew they're one of the crews i would
bet on because they've shown the ability
to create ip not just license it
espn scares me because they haven't
started another sport
they just rent it and to your point when
you lose the rights
what happens and the nba is not giving
them the rights in perpetuity i don't
know the details
no and to your point all the other ones
are in play right
so i would say the following
that's right comma their ability to
create ip
is something that needs to be thought
through and i don't know who on that
team did that or what that would be what
i would have looked under the hood on if
i was investing
to see if i felt that they could stand
up new things
and i believe it is the ip creators over
the next decade that win the biggest
andreas you want to step in here for for
a second
yeah absolutely gary you've been kind of
alluding to this uh
throughout this recording um you
basically have the clients you have the
distribution
and you have the resources so what are
you planning for
in this space is there a vayner nft
platform on the way and
uh what kind of other opportunities are
you exploring with your clients as well
on the client side i'm definitely
building out
internal expertise at vaynermedia
vaynerx my
services business um
to be able to help with you know
lightweight projects
not fully launching nfts and things of
that nature i am
currently in the process of really
gathering my thoughts on how big i like
to be frank andres i'm a little bit and
i'm not like this normally which is why
i know
um this is a big one i'm a little
i don't use the word overwhelmed i'm i
can feel like
the energy in my soul like this is big
for me and so i want to be very
thoughtful
i'm like how i capture this energy um
but i can tell you the following these
are facts because i want to give you
some scoops because i like you guys
thanks
it's impossible that i go to the grave
unless i die very quickly here
which would be very sad without
launching my own nft
product but i don't but it's not gonna
be gary b photos
like i'm not doing the influencer thing
there is no chance that i'm not
investing in the
shovels and the picks the platforms
i've already personally and more
institutionally
feel that i will invest in projects
meaning
i bought some hashbacks and crisp crypto
punks
as gary the human i plan on doing that
more institutionally
raising capital and doing that raising
capital and doing it against companies
and which is very different than what i
did in o5 right in 95 i built on top of
it winelibrary.com i believe in the
internet
in o5 i was like oh i've learned i'm not
going to just do that
i'm going to invest in the companies and
build up the garyvee brand
and that worked in 2021 with nfts i'm
gonna invest in the platforms
i'm gonna invest in projects because i'm
good at it like sports cards
and i think i have the creativity what i
did forget i'm the brains behind garyvee
and i think i can do that to something
more scalable all three are in the cards
for me sir
so you're gonna be busy so uh we
appreciate you uh making the time here
to unpack this for us and to
you know kind of i guess pop the scoops
nft
cherry so we appreciate that garyvee
thank you thanks for coming on thanks
for having me and final part
i pay attention to a lot of things you
you're you're doing really good work
keep it up youtube watcher what's up
it's garyvee first of all thank you so
much i hope you're doing super well
during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you